good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight an American Tragedy that's the
focus of tonight's
angle right shortly after that nightmare
attack Sunday on US service Personnel in
Jordan Republicans rushed out to demand
that Biden launch a significant military
retaliation against Iran now the loss of
these three Patriots is both
heartbreaking and enraging and while the
impulse to avenge their deaths is
understandable we cannot afford another
protracted conflict in the Middle East
and even if we could we can't rely on
this woke series of dimwits at the Biden
Pentagon to deliver anything resembling
Victory after all is Biden's top
military brass had success War gaming
Ukraine even tracking our Munitions
there and how did Million Austin manage
that Afghanistan withdrawal again to
this day after 13 US service Personnel
were left vulnerable then blown to bits
Biden has held no one in his
administration accountable no one but of
course he was busy because his Focus was
on more important things such as
advocating for transgenderism in the
military transitioning has allowed me to
be better as a leader um I've gotten rid
of the distraction of worrying about um
concealing who I really was Fox had to
rely on private insurance to cover her
surgery but from now on the military
will cover the cost of sex change
operations approved by a doctor our
doctors will treat them Med and give
them medically necessary treatment
according to the protocols oh the
protocols and they also put new
protocols in place to clear out
extremists meaning Trump supporters from
the military too extremism is not
tolerated in any branch of the United
States military if our law enforcement
Partners flag an individual uh based on
their determination that they see
something uh and they pass it to us um
we're not even asking what the flag was
we're just removing
them well the message was loud and clear
it was delivered that the biggest threat
we faced as a nation came from Trump
supporters especially those with
military training the cry for survival
comes from planet itself a cry that
can't be any more desperate or any more
clear and now arise of political
extremism white supremacy domestic
terrorism that we must confront and we
will
defeat well their six social justice
project in the military has coincided
with a jaw-dropping shortfall in
military recruitment which itself puts
our troops at risk well not that they
care now this partly explains how
America's military became such an easy
target
but specific questions have to be
answered like how is it despite our
sophisticated air defenses did a drone
managed to penetrate an army
Outpost and why is a unit of army
reservist Engineers stationed so close
to Syria in the first
place can Biden and Austin even stand
before reporters and answer questions
about this W that's doubtful so why
should we trust them to carry out
massive air strikes on Iran
now we reflexively call ourselves a
superpower because of our
nukes but I think it's worth asking do
superpowers commit economic and cultural
suicide like America has our enemies
aren't worried about Biden's response to
this latest attack they've been watching
us they're already emboldened the
Chinese spy balloon Odyssey eliminated
any doubt that Biden was another Jimmy
Carter he is and two years after Biden
pledged to isolate Russia by supporting
Ukraine Putin's more popular than ever
and Russia's GDP is growing four years
after China Unleashed covid-19 and
killed hundreds of thousands with
fentanyl and president X still has Biden
dancing to his
tune now we lost our way and our
leverage along the way because this is
the world that the globalists always
wanted where America had no right to be
self-sufficient had no right to be
wealthy where we gutted our
manufacturing base and our middle class
along with it a world where we attack
our own energy Independence apologize
for it even and then stick the taxpayers
with the bill a world where we leave our
own border open but go into debt and
have our grandchildren go into debt to
enforce other Count's borders a world
where post 911 we added $29 trillion to
our national debt think about it a world
where we teach our children to hate our
Founders and much of our own history
these are not the actions of a
superpower capable of taming Iran or
getting Russia to bend to our will this
instead is a slow rolling American
Tragedy and I hate saying this it pains
me to say this but we are not the
country we used to be we are much weaker
economically we are much weaker
culturally spiritually and we're much
weaker geopolitically than we were 20
years ago or even four years ago and the
more money and the more resources we
give to President Biden and his team of
incompetence the weaker we will
become so until we get a brand new
president bad things are going to
continue to happen there is really
nothing we can do about that at this
point but what we can do and what we
must do is prevent the Biden team from
doing any more harm by getting us into
foolish military Adventures that will
just result in more heartbroken American
families and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else